hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on apex legends and the
legendary ax hunt challenge rewards have
just been leaked on the PlayStation
Store currently as I'm making this it's
about 140 54 p.m. in Eastern Standard
Time so it's roughly not about the time
that the update is live it's still going
through those patches they [ __ ] up on
the updating so as I'm making this video
it is not live but probably when the
video is uploaded it should be going
live so you can go into the game and
check these out we're going to be going
over what certain type of skins and
weapon skins some which we haven't even
talked about yet what which ones can you
get and how you're going to achieve
those so real quick it's gonna be a
pretty quick video so there's always
like the V if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of apex legends that
being the updates the coverage of the
game and all that type of stuff as well
as covering the lore for every new hero
that comes into the game so if that
sounds interesting definitely stay
subscribe to the channel my twitter and
disk or to be in the description down
below if you guys want to check that out
and let's get started with today's video
so for this legendary hunt event it's
gonna be going from June 4th which is
today as I'm making this video to June
18th you'll roughly have about two weeks
to do all these challenges and get all
the stuff that you need and the stuff
they're gonna beginning is the legendary
hunting badge a rare scanner for the
g-seven scout an epic skin for
bloodhound a legendary skin for the
triple take as well as two legendary
skins one of them being an R 301 and the
raid skin which we've already previously
seen it but the g-seven scout and the
triple take are very new to us so first
up the very easy one is going to be the
R 301 and the r8 skin to get these skins
if you have the wild frontier battle
pass you will be getting the honoured
pray our 301 skin and for the right skin
if you've achieved level 15 before the
end of the event you will also get the
Wraith skin so you can get those very
easily level 15 is really not that hard
at all I think I'm like level 80 I
haven't played in a couple months but
yeah that's a very simple one and these
are actually a really cool skin so not a
lot of work for really cool looking
skins the other ones do require a little
bit of finesse and challenges so the
legendary hunt badge is the one that you
can equip on your player banner show it
off to everyone in game that is going to
be finishing top 5 in any match be rare
Skinner for the g7 Scout called wolf
pack all you have to do is finish a top
5 in the elite top 5 matches
for the epic skin for the master of the
bloodhound legend skin you have to
finish top five five times in any type
of queue and for the legendary skin the
tamed beast for the triple take you just
have to win twice in any queue
now the word queue is a little bit
different because that really doesn't
make any sense we have one game mode in
this game but as this update is going
live they added the elite queue
basically what that means is that if
your squad reaches top five you now have
eligibility to be in the elite queue so
the next time you queue up in your game
if you reach top five or higher then
anybody else
and throughout apex that gets into your
match will also be within the top 5 of
their game so there's gonna be one squad
of all top 5 players then your squads
gonna be top 5 players and then their
squad and every single squads match
basically making it just a little bit
harder it's not ranked but it's the
closest thing we have to a ranked game
and I'm assuming that might get higher
and higher as you keep climbing maybe
there will be two people within it or
it's just a bunch of people in the elite
top 5 but yeah that's considered the
elite queue and the other one I'm just
gonna call it the regular queue
throughout the rest of this video so the
badge just like I said you have to be
top 5 and any match very simple very
easy doesn't matter what cute is it
could be the elite or the regular for
the Wolfpack at g7 that's probably the
hardest one for this challenge
you have to get the top 5 in the regular
queue then go into the elite queue and
get top 5 in there so you have to go
back-to-back top 5s or even back-to-back
wins if you want and you'll get that for
the epic skin of bloodhound you have to
finish in the top 5 any time in any
queue that could just mean all 5 of them
being in the regular one of them being
in the regular four of them being in the
elite queue doesn't matter just get top
just get top 5 5 times throughout the
two weeks and you'll be completely
golden and the trip will take 1 which is
also very easy this is just winning
twice in any queue so you can win won
any regular and then go to the elite or
both of them could be getting from the
regular queue doesn't matter just get
two wins throughout the first two weeks
or the only two weeks of this event and
you'll get the legendary skin like I
stated before the other two are pretty
easy the are 301 and the raid skin just
require you to either have the battle
pass or be level 15 so honestly with
these two weeks you should be able to
get top 5 no problem I think the g7
Scout one's gonna be a little bit harder
since you have to go top 5 in an elite
top 5 match so you have to go
back-to-back that the one is probably
gonna be a little tricky the only thing
I can really see here is just
if you're really good at the game when
you get top fives and wins constantly
really just play how you're playing I
would highly recommend playing with the
team of three lots of communication
there which is gonna help a lot getting
to those wins in those top fives but if
you're like me and you play solo a lot I
completely understand that either just
get really lucky with the teammates you
have which can take some time which is
why they give us two weeks or if you're
really close to that top five mark I
would suggest me playing a little bit
more passively maybe not going for as
many kills of course the less kills you
have the better you know the worst sure
boots gonna be compared to other players
who are going on absolute rampages but
doesn't hurt to get a couple kills there
and back but I would just try to stay
passive and not go guns blazing trying
to kill 1/3 of the lobby in your match I
mean if you're confident with that then
by all means take you know just do your
thing well personally I like to play a
little passive when I'm in those top
five scenarios just so I can get that
little placement and that extra XP
that's just entirely my opinion let me
know what you guys think if you guys
have any ideas to get to top 5 or
getting any wins just some little quick
tip bits of information for people to
learn definite let me know in the
comments below it so everyone can be up
to date of what's happening and how to
get these skins the in weapons the
fastest yeah guys it's gonna be the end
of the beta hopefully you guys did enjoy
it like I said a small video just to
cover everything obviously as an like I
said as I'm making this video the update
is not live but of course this was
leaked on the PlayStation Store and
there really isn't much one of the
problems I do have with the legendary
hunt is that not every single person is
getting a skin which bothers me a lot
Pathfinder octane all those characters
are not getting one it's only Wraith and
bloodhound and not even all the weapons
are getting them our 301 trip will take
in g7 they're missing the devotion
they're missing the havoc at the r99 the
wingman all those weapons of course I'm
not gonna ramble on a name every single
weapon that would take a 10 minute video
but you get the point
not every single weapon is being
mentioned that kind of bothers me I
don't really know why that is the case
maybe they'll have another legendary
hunt in the future when season 2
releases but I feel like if you're gonna
do an event you got to give love to
every single weapon or every single
character at least because not everyone
plays bloodhound and not everyone plays
rate so the people that don't play those
characters I'm most likely not gonna
even care about those challenges you've
Lumino your thoughts in the comments
below about this stuff I think this was
pretty nice I don't think it was worth
the month and a half of time that we had
to wait for this stuff but maybe that
you're completely different let me know
in the comments below but like to be if
you do enjoy
skiver for new I covered the
informational side of Apex legends that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patches and the leaks so if
we want to be kept up today with
everything happening with it the world
of apex legends definitely stay
subscribe to the channel I also cover
the lore of Apex legends as well so if
you're wondering a little bit about the
backstory of the game and all the new
characters that release definitely stay
subscribe to the channel as well for
that my two most recent videos are going
to be popping up on screen if you guys
do want to check that out that guys hope
every wrister day thank for watch the
video good luck on all those skins and
peace out let me know which ones you
guys had by the time you watch this
video
[Music]
you